i gotcha
[Laughter]
my name is george moats and my job is to
protect the great american hamburger i
love
regional burgers because they are really
all about method not so much about
toppings but really about method about
how they're cooked whether they're
poached
steamed deep fried smoked but every once
in a while
there is a burger that represents that
region because of its topping only
and sometimes the toppings are literally
one ingredient
that's it today i'm going to take you on
a tour of regional toppings
things you can put on your smash burgers
or my smash burgers
let's smash together that sounds stupid
it's a topping speed round we're gonna
do toppings on
burgers right now four different
regional smash burgers
with different toppings that actually
represent real
regional burgers they're going to seem
kind of weird you have to understand
though that you must trust me
i've had these burgers i've been in
these regions i've been in these
restaurants
and they are all amazing
amazing i wouldn't be showing it to you
unless it was absolutely incredible
here we go speed round first up the
olive burger from central
michigan we don't know why the allen
burger started but we do know that it
did start the 1930s
at a restaurant called cupe in central
michigan
at some point somebody decided to take
some cocktail olives chop them up
and add some mayonnaise and put it on a
burger and that was it let's start with
the smash burger first we smash
smash salt and press
the topping is only three ingredients
i'm going to take some olives
chop them up oh that's got a pit of it
these are just regular cocktail olives
the kind you put in a martini for
example
[Music]
a little bit of mayonnaise right
and some brine just a little bit
to make a little bit runny which is also
kind of what you want because
there's so much creamy goodness in here
you don't need cheese it's weird because
you go outside of michigan
you're not going to find this burger
anywhere in fact if you go north of
michigan you're not going to find it if
you go to detroit you're not going to
find it it's really only in central
western and southern michigan that is a
hyper regional burger right there look
at this it's a toasted bun that's it one
toasted bun
a patty on the bun now this is going to
be a mess also i'm telling you right now
it's going to be a mess but somehow when
that briny
mayo meets beef it's the olive burger
from michigan
not much of a history but big on taste
oh let's do the butter burger keep up
you ready for this the butter burger
it's exactly what it sounds like
it's a burger with nothing more than
butter on it that's it just butter
this burger comes from wisconsin this
burger goes
all the way back for me because i
included the restaurant sally's in my
movie hamburger america almost 20 years
ago
this is sally's grill from glendale
wisconsin right next to milwaukee
and we serve the old-fashioned butter
burger
the butter burger is exactly what it
sounds like it's nothing more than
butter on a burger which we're gonna do
right now smash burger
this is actually fresh wisconsin butter
soft creamy wonderful wisconsin butter
yeah you can eat it oh
people in wisconsin take butter very
seriously so much so
that according to hang on a second
according to the wisconsin state
legislature in
section section 98 18
subsection 4 the serving of margarine
at a public eating place as a substitute
for butter
is prohibited punishable by a fine of up
to 500
or imprisonment you can go to jail in
wisconsin if you try to serve somebody
anything but butter in the restaurant
that's how serious they take it
so obviously if you're having a butter
burger and you're in wisconsin
you're in pretty good hands i'll tell
you right now now wisconsin what they do
especially at sally's they take the top
of the bun right this has been toasted
and they put a very large almost
two to three tablespoon dollop of butter
on the burger now this seems ridiculous
i know but the minute that that
semi-soft butter hits that hot patty
boom once that melted butter starts to
escape
onto the plate as you take bites you dip
the burger back into the plate for more
butter
[Laughter]
butter as a condiment that's right
only in wisconsin next burger on the
topping speed round
the green chili cheeseburger whoa have
you ever had one they're incredible
green chili is an icon of new mexico
it's part of pretty much
every piece of new mexican cuisine i
like to say that jalapeno is kind of
like a
slap in the face and green chili is like
a
punch in the gut most people who eat
cheeseburgers in new mexico wouldn't
think of eating anything else but
a green chili cheeseburger basically
stewed green chilies
there's nothing in here but i put a
little bit of chicken stock really it's
just water
a little bit of chicken stock and
chopped roasted green chilies because
most of the flavor from a roasted green
chili does come from the roasting
process
because it's very smoky these are really
smoky
and very spicy it's my and they're very
spicy and they do
release a lot of a lot of heat
a little bit of salt
[Music]
you're probably wondering what this
thing is back here i bet you're all
thinking like
what the [ __ ] is in his living room what
does that thing people sometimes think
is this thing is an extension of my hair
that is an actual tumbleweed from the
trinity site in new mexico
in fact i was getting a green chili
cheeseburger once very close to the
trinity site
and this thing rolled across the road
and i brought it home
that's right i brought it home green
chili will fall over the place
so what they do is they actually put the
green chili onto the patty as it's
cooking
and then they envelop that green chili
on the patty
with white american cheese i'm also
going to do this to
do some melting action that sounds like
oh
[Music]
it's okay okay sorry i'll come back in a
minute
oh [ __ ] oh yes
oh yeah okay
you see this wow
oh yeah that's perfect
[Music]
there oh the green chili cheeseburger
in my house
now that is a topping
oh and it's just what's amazing about
this burger
is that green chilies are hot obviously
anytime you eat spicy food it releases
endorphins when you're releasing
endorphins you feel kind of high
so in a way this burger kind of makes
you high
gives you a little buzz
[Laughter]
spicy that's very spicy it's very spicy
it's very spicy and i'm getting high
right now
topping speed round continues let's do
one more
next step in the speed round the nut
burger the nut burger it's not made of
nuts it's not some kind of walnut burger
some
vegan situation no this is a burger that
has a
nut sauce on top sorry i know you're
thinking
keep chuckling keep chuckling keep
chuckling you're done yet okay yes
it has nut sauce this comes from a place
only one place
it's not even a regional specialty it's
a specialty of the house of one
burger spot in montana in butte montana
place called matt's place matt's place
is also on the national historic
register okay
this is a very important hamburger place
with a very important burger
you have to take the nut burger
seriously nut sauce is only two things
okay it's made from miracle whip and
crushed salted peanuts i guarantee
you're thinking to yourself
wait what nuts in miracle whip it's a
crazy combination of flavors
and somehow it works i'm going to start
with a
smashed patty they walk over to the
sundae bar which is they sell ice cream
also
and they grab a handful of crushed nuts
so i need to crush them first i'm going
to take some parchment paper
i'm just gonna use my spatula
and crush crush the nuts
and they literally grab a coffee mug and
they put the nuts
into a coffee mug i'm not sure why this
happens but this seems to be some kind
of weird tradition
put miracle into the mug and they stir
it up
butte montana was known for its copper
mines very famous copper mines in the
turn of the century
who knows it could have been some
old-timer copper miner who was like
give me something special give me
miracle whip and nuts
and there you have it nut sauce mmm
that is yeah yum yum yum
yes i love smash burgers
they get that crispy edge it's almost
like beef candy right there it's awesome
it's chewy
and crispy and good and when you add
beef candy to nut sauce
oh my goodness stand back whoa that's it
nothing else no lettuce no tomato no
foie gras
i know you're thinking right now holy
[ __ ] i'm not eating that
well i am it's [ __ ] good
it's still hot man
i can't i can't understand why this
didn't get out there in the world the
nut burger
yeah oh wow mmm
that's incredible that's a lacy edge
thank you for coming on this journey
with me now go make your own
because you can do this you have these
ingredients in your house
you may not have green chili in your
house or
america web but you have most of those
things
so go make it happen just like i did
and then go take a nap or don't go on a
bike ride go to bike ride
no no you might throw up go take a nap